is PT is engulfing burg to get hands on
a rather hands-free experience with
autonomous driving although we do have a
human driver on board - I have a
driver's license why I'm not allowed to
drive a car yes this is an early
prototype of our autonomous vehicle and
the system is not complete yet so I
still have to supervise the system and I
still have to take care of some
scenarios by myself but it will give you
a preview of the future of commuting at
first glance this looks like any other
Volvo s60 in fact it's fitted with radar
sensors a front view camera and GPS
let's see how it copes with traffic and
Gothenburg on the Beltway and Aleya
shows us how the car drives itself on
certain sections I will activate the
system now so I just push this button so
now I can throw my hands
and the system will adapt to the traffic
in front it will reduce the speed when
necessary and it will follow the line I
have removed my feet from the palace so
it handled the acceleration and brakes
and also the steering by itself
autonomous driving is gaining traction
in the automotive world and Volvo is not
the only car maker researching the
possibilities what makes the drive me
scheme and Sweden special is that it
boasts an all-round package it's a joint
initiative cooking of Volvo's technology
with the city of Gothenburg swallow's
government agencies
we offer the space of the city so that
they because have somewhere to to to
drive so we are going to use the
ordinary roads around the city of
Gothenburg so that's our input to the
project but also we we are very keen on
seeing the results and see how we can
integrate this in a city planning
traffic on the Ring Road can get really
heavy during rush hour exactly the right
environment for an autonomous car it
allows the driver to sit back and relax
and devote that time to other activities
it also allows present infrastructure to
be used more efficiently autonomous cars
are able to drive at a short distance to
each other in addition to freeing up
traffic space that saves fuel by
profiting from the preceding vehicle
slipstream expect the infrastructure to
be more compact and that we can use land
in a better way that the lanes may be
narrower and that we can avoid
congestion in a far better way than
today and of course that we expect also
with autonomous driving fully
implemented that we have almost zero
accidents and incidents which we also
contribute to
a sustainable future the car does not
yet have sensors to perform a 360-degree
scan so for now the driver has to do the
lane changing when parking however the
driver doesn't even need to be in the
car at all this is a task the cars can
do completely independently
autonomous driving opens up new
opportunities on the stationary traffic
front self parking cars will mean more
efficient use of parking garages and
less frustration for drivers
a look ahead to the future instead of
endless circles in the garage next to
the mall shoppers can drop their car off
at the entrance and then use their phone
to activate autonomous parking the
vehicle sets up and uses sensors to
localize and navigate itself to a free
space
once the driver is done shopping he
pushes a button on a cell phone that
tells the car to return to the drop-off
zone and the scenario it's the car that
picks up the driver
Alton with penises sure this development
will make driving safer but as it
ultimately depends on the driver there
is an attention sensor it monitors the
movement of the driver's eyes even if
you're wearing glasses if the driver is
unable to retake control because they've
fallen asleep or is unwell the car will
engage certain measures to alert them
that might be a pull on the belt or
shaking the seat if the driver fails to
respond the car will exit traffic and
park itself all sign-ins I've done it's
introduced uncommon the attention sensor
is one of a number of pre-existing
assists that Volvo has taken to the next
level instead of investing in complex
and completely new technologies it's
that approach that the car maker hopes
will help keep the concept at a
reasonable cost for consumers
and the aim is very clear our society is
changing our needs are changing the
needs for a transportation system are
changing this is what we are here to
make this revolution to give people back
their time and do this in a safe manner
and also thinking about the environment
it's important that the package is
affordable otherwise we cannot make any
impact on a society we cannot give you
our customers the benefit Volvo is also
thinking of its own future - of course
future cars catering to future needs are
bound to sell well but then there are
the legal complexities who is liable of
an autonomous car has an accident
it's a challenge but if we want
development we have to see that our
legislation is following the development
in society and laws has been changed
before so there is no loss we who are
written in in stone you have to change
laws when the development takes place
but of course you have to guarantee the
safety as well 2017 will be crunched and
hopefully not crash time for Volvo the
drive me scheme envisage is letting
loose a hundred cars on selected streets
in and around gothenburg by then the
autonomous fleet will explore the social
and technical challenges involved in
hands-free driving the next step in the
evolution of the driverless car